regardez on se parle de ça aujourd'hui
on se parle du sony xperia one man 4
alors il a été présenté il ya quelques
temps ça fait quelques temps que je lis
avec moi que je me balade que je
l'essaie que je m'amuse et que ce
smartphone je ne trouve pas intéressant
pourquoi alors s'en rend compte il ya
quelques années je vous parle
effectivement de sony on a vu
l'évolution a vu arriver le sony xperia
juan marque un mark 2 mark iii le marque
4 cette année et je me suis dit je vous
le disais en alliant je me disais ouais
j'ai l'impression que ce n'est en fait
ils prennent pas les choses dans le bon
sens parce que ils vont toujours dans
l'idée d'être un peu à part et ils vont
pas lire dans l'idée du grand public ce
que veulent les gens aujourd'hui c'est
un smartphone en prend aux shoots sans
peyton shoot c'est à dire on veut pas se
prendre la tête avec configurer son
smartphone on veut que ce soit simple
sauf que et là où c'est intéressant on
voit l'évolution du marché on va être
plus en plus de smartphones et qu'à
force tout finit par se ressembler et ce
qui faisait un peu la faiblesse de ce
nid à savoir un truc très différents et
un peu loin de cet univers android très
simple au niveau de la photo notamment
parce qu'après il ya tout le reste il ya
à l'audio il ya l'écran essayer ça mais
du point de vue photo vidéo j'ai trouvé
un petit peu loin parce que trop
différent et bien comme il ya une
uniformisation ils tirent leur épingle
du jeu et ça c'est intéressant et voyez
le temps travaille pour eux pour autant
est-ce que ce smartphone est fait pour
tout le monde je ne suis pas convaincu
je vais vous montrer ça parce que le
sony c'est le mastodonte japonais on
connaît maçonné la pictures sony music
sony 6,10 à lasser les smartphones c'est
pas forcément la division qui fonctionne
le mieux mais qui évolue et c'est plutôt
cool d'ailleurs je les ai pas dans le
podcast aller jeter un coup d'oeil mon
podcast fréquence greuze sur youtube ou
alors dans toutes les bonnes crémeries
c'est super intéressant parce que
justement que c'est une interview d'à
peu près une demi heure 38 minutes et on
parle on comprendra le positionnement
voie où est-ce qu'ils ont sont vos skis
en solo termes de parts de marché où ils
vont aller quérir vision donc ça vous
invite vraiment à me revoir donc
aujourd'hui on va regarder ce smartphone
doit regarder si au final ce qu'ils
demandent pas une vue faisait les
faiblesses à un instant t fait je fais
pas mon truc tu finiras pas le gâteau
fait plutôt la force de se lier
aujourd'hui est ce que cette force est
fait pour tout le monde ou pas et
qu'est-ce qui nous apporte de 9 en 2022
avec cet xperia ou anne maaf 4
déjà ça dézingue qui est très à part
très à part pourquoi parce que l'on
retrouve un peu at on pas un peu à
l'ancienne mais sony a décidé de marquer
son design et de le garder dans le temps
et pourquoi pas c'est différent c'est
intéressant si vous comparez avec
d'autres smartphones voyait là par
exemple sous la main j'ai magic 4 trop
de honor c'est très différent c'est
beaucoup plus large on a un gros truc au
milieu c'est plus fins et légers c'est
mignon donc le format est cool super
bonne prise en main mais ça c'est pas du
tout nouveau et ça se déverrouille bien
avec le capteur d'empreintes digitales
et ça c'est canon déjà construit qui est
intéressant ici sony y maîtrise les
dalles on a le côté sony bravia qui nous
apporte cette dalle de superbe qualité
qui est plus lumineuse que ce qu'on
avait les années précédentes un bref
tous les ans vous savez les fabricants
de smartphones nous apporte des
évolutions ici ou là aussi donc bon de
ce point de vue là ça marche
l'expérience audio de très bonnes en
plus de ça et regarder ils nous ont fait
le retour de la prise d'acte c'était
l'année dernière qui est juste là donc
si vous êtes des audiophiles voulu dire
brancher un casque vous l'avez si vous
voulez un casque également jean sérien -
whb xl5 et bien vous et vous connecter
entre elles dac dessus vous avoir une
superbe qualité donc l'expérience
multimédia visionnage séries philes vous
avez un tout petit à petit il pareil
pour la puissance pour le gaming vous
avez un truc qui marche vachement bien
vous avez un super smartphones très
performants tout ce côté là si vous
voulez ça fonctionne pas de souci mais
d'autres qui est intéressant tu vas
vraiment venir nous intéresser ici c'est
la partie création photo vidéo parce que
ce smartphone là pour brown il n'est pas
fait pour monsieur et madame tout le
monde si monsieur et madame tout le
monde des smartphones ne veut pas
s'embêter que la partie photo vidéo on
dira si on veut aller chez sony sur un
ex-paria 10 ans qui sera très bien aussi
un xperia 10 mark iv qui est également
sorti donc pourquoi pas mais là si on
vole et là dessus c'est convalescence 4
mieux aujourd'hui en termes de photos de
vidéos pour autant regarder il ya
toujours cette fameuse application alors
ce application je vous l'avoué je
n'entrais elle est intéressante mais
elle est très différente un menu basique
un menu auto et après on rentre dans
tous les paramètres un peu plus complexe
pour arriver sur quelque chose d'un peu
plus j'ai pas ya professionnel c'est pas
vrai mais pour les connaisseurs qui
veulent l'expérience sony alpha par leur
poche donc ça c'est cool après vous
allez retrouver vidéo pro ou revenir à
voir à l'expérience pour venir shooter
ou via choisir ici son objectif le zoom
si on veut venir sous mais là on va
avancer doucement doucement doucement
doucement voyons voir 200 375 mm et on
va redescendre descendre descendre ici
en 16 mm donc la voyez on est vraiment
sur une notion de photos un plus pro par
rapport à ce qu'on a sur un smartphone
un peu classique donc cette application
- je vais pas forcément venir l'utiliser
parce que c'est pas celle qui va
m'intéresser celle qui va m'intéresser
c'est l'application un peu plus grand
public l'application vous allez
retrouver là et puis après vous avez
d'autres applications cinéma pro ou là
vous allez voir venir aussi vous amuser
votre résolution votre objectif bon là
c'est plus pour les gens qui veulent
venir à tout y est mais pour moi le truc
le plus intéressant ici ça va être ta
plat parce que vous permet de faire à
peu près tout pas tous très bien mais à
peu près tous je vous montre le software
au niveau de la caméra alors le truc qui
est pas mal c'est que vous voyez là vous
avez votre foi ça sera très bien c'est
clair on a le x 07 qui est très clair
ici on tue très grand-angle là entre les
deux là c'est du zoom numérique la
joviale optique la chance ou numérique
juste assez de vue là 3.05 où je passe
ça directement et sinon unique et la
cure de plus j'espère quoi 5 à 0 2 et la
presse et tout numérique jusqu'à la fois
15,15 réglisse le seul truc qui est un
peu relou c'est que lorsque je suis
enfin j'ai pas accès avant vous tic donc
obligés de venir monter ici pour la voix
et lorsqu'on fait de la vidéo c'est pas
toujours très pratique et autre truc
c'est que lorsque je parle de tout
envoyer du x 0 c'était que je vous
montre tout en effet obligé de relever
mon doigt pour choper parce que j'ai pas
accès à tous comme ça ça passe mal on l
espèce de petite molette là on l'a pas
donc le système de zoom est pas parfait
mais bon ça dépend des trois décès dont
vous avez besoin sipa demande bien la
reconnaissance lisent ça c'est cool ça
marche bien là je suis sans le mode
basique à pour la dot mode pourquoi on
va voir ça c'est pour le côté photos raw
avenue je sors de là je reste je repasse
en mode basique
pour moi le temps qu'il fasse mon bien
c'est la grosse innovation café ici
saunier ça faut vraiment venir le
souligner parce que c'est l'innovation
majeure à savoir que il vous intègre un
zoom optique variable alors c'est un
petit moteur en fait qui va venir à
faire bouger votre gentille mais cette
fois qui est intéressant parce que
autant des fois on va avoir des
smartphones avec des zoom périscopique
où on va aller très loin on voit qu'on a
un zoom optique qui va être fixé il faut
1 m de zoom optique prend deux focales
différents qu'après on avance on vous
numérique donc on est dégradé un peu la
qualité alors ici on a effectivement
cette expérience qui nous permet d'avoir
tous en zoom optique pour autant ce
qu'on va retrouver ici à la différence
qu'on va avoir entre le x 3,5 et le x
5,2 est pas énorme ça reste extrêmement
proches n'y a pas une très grosse
différence dans l'image mais malgré tout
ce que je viens vraiment souligner ici
c'est l'innovation ça fait d'apporter
cette nouveauté donc ça c'est très bien
on est sur 85 jusqu'à 1 125 totalement
d'optique ça c'est cool mais une fois de
plus centré sera aux personnes qui sont
amoureux de la photo et la vidéo alors
qu'avant on était sur un zoom numérique
quel et 70 505 autre nouveauté
intéressante vous avez de la 4k cent
vingt 120 ça veut dire quoi tient dans
une seconde vous avez 120 images plus
vous en été et plus et pouvoir ralentir
étirer le temps en ayant de la fluidité
avant vous l'aviez sur le capteur
principal votre grand-angle à vous
l'avez sur les 3 capteurs donc très bien
belle évolution également toujours à
tout est génial chez sony d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça que j'utilise - un boîtier
de sony j'allais à 7s croire parce que
vous avez vraiment le suivi le yatch de
voyage un petit carré voiliers haut
niveau demande à yoff à vous le voyez
pas mais j'ai un petit tiers au niveau
de l'oeil et ce truc là il vraiment
peuple parce qu'en fait ça ne décroche
pas vous être assuré et on retrouve
cette techno là et sony va également
plus loin en apportant des possibilités
de live stream donc s'intéresse vraiment
aux créateurs on vient vraiment les
draguer donc si vous êtes créateur je
voulais venir streamé avec votre
smartphone vous pouvez venir le faire
s'adressera pas à tout le monde se
redressera déjà des personnes qui stream
autant dire qu on dit un petit peut
réduire le panel stream et est en plus
streamés sur smartphone donc le panel
est très fin mais en tout cas et ce qui
est bien c'est qu'en fait ce smartphone
et je pense vraiment c'est un smartphone
qui est un peu un couteau suisse du
créateur que ce soit en photo que ce
soit en vidéo également fournir stream
et faire plein de choses on a un
smartphone qui est performant et qui
rentrent pas je dirais dans les travers
de certains smartphones qui vont venir
toucher trop les algorithmes derrière et
dénaturer un peu d'esprit photo et c'est
ça qui est intéressant aussi c'est avec
sony regardez c'est ça que j'aime bien
chez sony c'est l'idée de se dire on
préserve le côté photo on est sur le
côté photo on voit bien le style or il
ya un traitement en arrière ça vous fait
ressortir le ciel en plein jour pour
autant on voit bien la façade devant
mais ça va pas venir le trop est
exacerbée si vous voulez cette façade là
et c'est cet esprit photos qu'on va me
retrouver tout au long la chaussure
monde ultra grand-angle c'est pareil
c'est un truc qui marche bien qui est
très très correct alors je viens me
rapprocher jeu mais un peu voyez pareil
de la même manière ici ils sont venus
chercher le truc un petit peu peut-être
chili avec un grand ciel bleu europe
soleil les zones d'ombré je vois dans
mes zones dont mais pour autant il n'y a
pas un travail algorithmique qui va me
faire ressortir certaines choses qui au
niveau de la photo normale ne
ressortirait pas donc on est dans une
maîtrise de sa photo sur eux car
certaines choses on peut le dire faire
avec ces paramètres on peut venir
gratter gratouiller je suis resté en
automatique j'ai pas débrayé en manuel
parce que pour moi l'idée c'était
vraiment ce lien on reste dans côté paul
fait une chute mais pour autant avec une
application un peu dédié donc ça c'est
plutôt cool et ça marche super bien l'
ultra grand-angle aussi je trouve très
fonctionnel et qui va bien donc là on
est sur le 85 optique là on est sur le
125 optique voyez alors après est ce
qu'on va venir retrouver ce qui est un
peu de jours la voyez là ici le
personnage ici est un peu cramé versus
de l'autre côté et là on a vraiment un
flou de bougé au niveau de ce monsieur
est également au niveau de cette dame
qui avant son influx de bouger alors
c'était un peu la limite c'est vrai qu'à
certains smartphones qui voudront
peut-être un tout très nette en
quelqu'un marche ici vous voudrez cette
notion de bouger une fois de plus ce
sont deux photos quelqu'un bouge bon
voilà faudrait venir rentrer dans les
paramètres après manuel pour venir se
mettre dans des ouvertures un peu plus
rapide plage sur deux au numérique et
ont étouffé la limite 6 8 et c'est
imprécis c'est pas terrible mais bon
voilà voilà jusqu'où on peut aller si
vous êtes en mode grand-angle et votre
ultra grand angle pour moi vous avez un
truc qui marche vachement bien mais une
fois de plus dans l'esprit
photographique on zoome en optique on va
plus loin nos petits voiliers ya
vraiment pas beaucoup de différence
aurait une petite différence entre le 85
125 et puis ensuite on va jusqu'au bout
c'est hors de vous montrer mais bon
voilà on va éviter mais ce qu'on sait
bien j'ai une jolie photo je trouve un
peu saturé un poil saturé si au niveau
des verts après ce que je veux dire
parfois reprocher c'est bien qu'on ait
une stabilisation optique moi qui ai un
tremblement essentiel c'est pas la
meilleure stabilisation que je la
trouvais jolie trouver les meilleurs fed
et sur d'autres smartphones vraiment ça
ne bouge pas beaucoup ici ça bouge un
peu et notamment lorsque j'ai un film
est un peu en vidéo c'est des fois un
peu un peu limite mais pour moi parce
que j'ai un tremblement essentiel est
qu'il me faudrait un grand bol je pense
ici voyez bâtiment pris à contre jour de
la même manière dont je suis venu
chercher un peu la petite bête ans il ya
quelques quelques limites aussi il ya un
côté un peu sursaturé mais sinon je
trouve ça plutôt assez jolie en la
caméra de celle fille sont venus
augmenter on est passé d'une 8
mégapixels à une 12 mégapixels bon c'est
pas le truc le plus transcendant du
siècle mais très honnêtement je trouve
que la qualité est moyenne beaucoup de
smartphones et notamment des smartphones
chinois qui vont venir vous lis et le
grade qui vont un peu trop loin je
trouve qu'ici on a un truc qui est très
naturel au niveau de la caméra de celle
fille est dans l'esprit un peu
photographique froidfond c'est pas mal
voilà regardez je montre un peu on fait
défiler en garde un peu ses photos et là
je suis sur zoom numérique a foncé sur
le 15 et quelques et on peut voir
monsieur pigeon garder de la même
manière ici son sabot garder au plat pas
ici grand temps du très grand temps que
la colorimétrie est quasiment la mère
des petites différences et un peu plus
chaud sur le grand temps de versus ultra
grand-angle là c'est pareil voyez up la
85 125 par le taf effet avec son travail
caméra de celle ci comme ça il faut une
perche 1 parce que si je fais comme ça
je suis très très proches en plus
stressant alors il me reconnais bien il
reconnaît bien les visages france prend
la perche on se met loin et là ça va un
peu mieux mais voyez je vais être un peu
sombre comme ça mais bon je vais me
tenir un peu moins parce que si je me
filmer comme sens elfique je le mets pas
un peu loin et 20
voyez up pas ouf on switch sur
la caméra arrière comme ça alors on est
vraiment dans l'idée photo/vidéo voyez
pas ce que ça à pain de viande
surexposés à c'est très très sombre tout
ce qu'on a dans cette zone là là c'est
très clair si j'appuie en bas à gauche
ça me fait un petit focus dessus mais
c'est tout j'ai suivi que je peux venir
annulé mais sinon on est vraiment dans
l'esprit vidéo là dessus pourquoi et
c'est ça qui est intéressant avec sony
c'est que je trouve que les employés il
reste vraiment dans l'idée vidéo pro
photo pro ils ne font pas des trucs
complètement dingos on peut passer sur
l'ultra grand temps que c'est très
naturel en fait être vraiment on
connaître les bases de la photo et de la
vidéo pour avoir quelques lignes ici et
c'est pas mal le mieux ici c'est encore
de le prix de leur tournée comme ça et
devenir ce film est comme ça voilà comme
ça vous filmez et vous aurez la
meilleure optique pour le meilleur
résultat pour le meilleur rendu j'aime
bien l'idée en tout cas après ce
smartphone ne s'arrête pas à la photo et
à la vidéo va beaucoup plus loin on a
une plus grosse batterie on passe de
quatre mais cinq cents millions de
terreur à 5000 alors je sais pas où est
ce qu'ils ont mimé bon forcément à
l'intérieur ils ont dû faire des choix
pour permettre d'avoir une batterie un
peu plus grosse autre truc qui soit
c'est très tendance actuelle vous avez
juste votre boîte vous avez rien à
l'intérieur juste le smartphone il n'y a
pas de câble il n'y a pas de chargeur on
est sûr de l'écoresponsabilité ici avec
une boîte en plastique et je pense à
priori en matériaux recyclables marcano
plastique in packaging ok on a toujours
ce grand écran 4 ko led avec une superbe
qualité d'affichage toujours le capteur
d'empreintes digitales sur la tranche
qui permet de déverrouiller au plat
rapidement après il faut aimer
l'expérience je pense que ça va être le
truc vraiment de se dire est ce que
j'aime l'expérience sony je trouve que
pour moi c'est pas l'expérience la plus
sexy au niveau est parce qu en fait le x
c'était un peu le point faiblissent
toute l'expérience utilisateur au niveau
de la navigation soft je trouve que
c'est pas très sexy il y aurait des
choses à venir chercher pour venir sexy
fier et emmener le truc un peu plus loin
que ce soit au niveau de l'application
photo le rendre un peu plus sexy ya
plein de paramètres appel on peut faire
plein de choses des fois il ya des
choses qu'on peut venir faire en dessous
d'autres l'application vidéo prouve
entre l'application photo qui fait vidéo
et des choses qui se mélange un peu
c'est toujours tout et je me reprocher
parce que quand on prend un smartphone
comme ça en main et bien aussi perd ce
smartphone je trouve très cool il fait
plein de jolies choses il n'est pas dans
le même idée de beaucoup de smartphones
voyez là je dirais que l'opposé de ce
smartphone pour moi ça va être
google 1 pixel six mois pixels si ce
procès pour moi l'opposé parce que vous
avez vraiment deux mondes totalement
différents avec un pixel syspro celui-là
avec le pixel syspro vous allez
totalement automatique vous appuyez ça
fait tout pour vous vous avez la
photographie computationnelle derrière
donc c'est l'ia qui va venir optimiser
votre photo qui des fois être un peu
trop poussif mais qui sera un côté un
peu magique si vous voulez parce que
google va venir faire un tour pour vous
ici y a rien de magique ici c'est à vous
de venir gérer donc c'est vraiment un
smartphone qui du coup se niche un petit
peu bien que vous ayez un truc super en
affichage voulez vous il eu d'autres
qualités bien bousiller les bons connais
qui vont bien avec les casques de sony
pour optimiser l'expérience vous avez un
truc qui est bien mais dès qu'on arrive
dans la partie photo vidéo ils veulent
mettre le maximum le truc le meilleur
qualité dans l'idée de l'xperia et des
fois on s'y perd un petit peu c'est
vraiment ce que j'ai approché mais si
vous êtes amoureux de sony si vous
utilisez comme moi un boîtier solide et
si vous voulez retrouver une expérience
photographique et vidéo et non pas un
truc tout automatique eh bien vous
trouverez votre bonheur ici mais je
pense que ce smartphone s'adresse à très
peu de personnes de par ses
spécifications qui sont vraiment un peu
nicher pour autant est-ce que c'est un
bon smartphone oui est ce que c'est un
beau smartphone oui est ce que le format
est canon oui je trouve ça chouette mais
vraiment pas fait pour tous nos
extrêmement riche et mais pour autant je
trouve que sony se démarque sony fait un
truc différent par rapport à tous les
autres et ça c'est plutôt intéressant
parce que ça va dans le sens du
consommateur alors je suis pas sûr
qu'ils en vendent les caisses je pense
pas que ce soit le but mais conviennent
montrer évolution après évolution
génération après génération que sony
reste fidèle à ses valeurs restent
fidèle à ses idées reste fidèle à son
engagement en allant servir les patients
des photos les amoureux de vidéos tous
ceux qui veulent un super smartphone
sans concession et à tarif de je ne sais
plus j'ai pu doter
1399 euros donc autant vous dire qu'on
n'est pas sur un smartphone qui va être
là pour tout le monde mais si vous
voulez un truc cool que vous êtes
photographe que vous êtes vidéaste que
vous voulez un beau smartphone il
intéressant vous pouvez en plus utilisé
tous les accessoires du profit dessus
c'est à dire vous allez avoir votre
petite poignée pour unir le piloter
lancé à voir le moniteur derrière
pouvoir installer un micro externe parce
que la qualité là dessus et pas folle au
niveau du micro mais c'est normal donc
voila moi je suis plutôt satisfait et
heureux alors pour autant est-ce que moi
alors que je suis créateur de contenu et
que j'ai effectivement aujourd'hui un
boîtier sony alpha est ce que je me
pourrez switcher tout le temps sur un
ex-paria one mark iv la réponse est non
je trouve intéressant mais je pense qu'à
des choses à venir bosser un peu comme
je vous disais au niveau de l'expérience
logiciel pour je me retrouve mais c'est
cool et je dois reconnaître que le
boulot de sony là dessus et fait j'ai
hâte de découvrir les générations
suivantes et suivantes et suivantes et
surtout par rapport au marché qui évolue
dans une autre question il faut de plus
un livre le podcast parce que tout sera
expliqué nord sur ce je vous embrasse
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez de
ce smartphone est ce que vous pourriez
vous laisser tenter ce que vous pourriez
aller dessus ou alors absolument pas
marqué le mois d'août le moins
intéressant à bientôt pour lé soin de
vous des bisous ciao
[Musique]